(electronic music)
- You loose?
- Warming it up.
- Okay so--
(burping)
- Getting the air out.
- [Abby] Dude why don't you
just buy the Mr. Crazy Legs app?
- Well, I obviously spent
so much on the outfit
that I think it's irresponsible
to also subscribe
to an entire app.
- Okay, alright, so you're
just gonna watch me?
- Yes, so, you watch
the video on the app,
I'll watch you, it's
like a game of telephone
but with our bodies.
- Okay.
Alright, are you ready to
move with Mr. Crazy Legs?
- Yas.
- [Video] Mr. Crazy Legs.
Let's get started
with frog jump kicks.
- Frog jump kicks, here we go.
(electronic music)
- Ah, oh, ah, oh.
- Alright they're
moving into twisteroos.
- Okay, twisteroos,
you're perfect, shit.
- So I'm really trying
to mimic the instructor.
- Good, I'm mimicking you ,
and that's how this works.
- Great, love it.
- Dude, I love the way
your ponytail whips.
- Yeah, me too.
(electronic music)
- I wish you could
just go topless
and just wear a
bra all the time.
- Dude, like I don't
like this commentary.
- Sorry.
- Okay here we go.
Raised camel.
- Can I see it from the side?
I don't understand the form
with the black leggings.
- So it's like you're
up and then you drink.
You're up and then
the camel drinks.
- Wow, okay, so you stick
your butt out like that
and your chest out like that?
- Yeah, and then you
really use your core
and then you spread
the bones behind.
- Yeah, spread em.
- What the fuck are
you doing, dude?
- I get it.
- You got the detail on it?
- Yeah, got it, got it.
- Good.
Do you need me to move closer?
- I need to see the
back a little more.
- Well it's just like
right left you know?
And so you can should
feel it in your core.
I've done this class before.
- [Ilana] Ow!
(crashing)
- Ilana, you okay?
- [Ilana] Yeah I'm good.
- Are you alright?
(laughing)
(electronic music)
(hip hop music)